thank you so much I just I want to
invite all the creators of Grendel who
are here please come up on the stage
with me and while they're coming up I've
got a long list of people that I would
like to thank first of all I'd like to
thank Brigham Young University and
especially my professors Bryan Adams
Kelly loose-leaf death holidays Sam
Nielsen Paris Eggbert and Erin Ludwig
thank you so much for all of your help
and support I'd like to thank the donors
to the BYU animation program you made
making this film possible and now I'd
like to give a special thank you to all
of my classmates and colleagues from BYU
who worked so hard and for so long on
Grendel and who trusted me in me from
the beginning to direct the film to what
it is now thank you so much and thank
you to the composer Christian Walker and
to the sound designer Jared Richardson
thank you especially to Austin Rodriguez
for his help and excellent support as a
producer for Grendel thank you to all my
professors over the years and especially
to Craig Hanson who started me on my
artistic journey and fine and I would
like to thank all of the understanding
families of everyone who worked on our
film especially I would like to thank my
family my mom and my dad and all of my
sisters who are and always have been my
biggest supporters I love you all and
thank you and then I would like to thank
the Academy
I never thought those words would come
out of my mouth I'd like to thank the
Academy for acknowledging our film and
all the hard work that went into it and
thank you Shawn Hector and Denise for
setting up all of inspiring events this
week and for introducing me to the other
amazing and skilled student academy
winners I'm so humbled to have our film
stand next to theirs thank you so much
[Applause]